I know you were friends with Lisa Marie
Presley you actually yeah yeah yes and
uh and and I was shocked to learn that
she had reached out to you to actually
uh help her with her album everyone
wants your help but
I guess you were busy she was busy it
didn't work out but uh the confusion on
that is is I think she wanted me to do
more and I was super busy and we were
friends and so I did do some work but
looking back I wished I'd sort of taken
more possession of it because she never
really got her music thing off the
ground and she was she was actually
really talented and it's a shame if you
get a chance to hear voice she inherited
a lot of her father's great
um depth in the voice and it's a shame
that she didn't make more music nice
woman she was awesome she was awesome
it's a
that's a tough one that was really hard
for me because she was she was she's one
a one of a kind person the the world
really didn't know her because of course
they always know her Elvis's daughter
but she was a really really cool unique
person did she ever talk to you about
Elvis we talked about her father a lot
in fact she had very fond memories of
her father and I think she was seven or
eight when he passed so she did remember
him and and she she had really glowing
things to say about her father I got I
got to know her father through her in a
way that I've never seen in public
so I got this like first front row seat
of what Elvis the person was like and if
you know what Elvis the person was like
from her perspective Elvis is even more
amazing than he already is it's kind of
crazy but he was really a unique person
were you an Elvis fan I mean I it it was
totally lost on me I think the
difficulty with Elvis is is if you look
at it from completely a musicology point
of view he's arguably the single most
important musical artist you know since
they started recording artists
because no one changed things more than
he did the problem is what happens
afterwards he gets in the music business
he starts making the schlocky movies
right his talent was
You could argue greater than any any
singular person in music's ever had
Talent
hey his talent was was at a level that's
almost incomparable I mean it's like
Michael Jackson and Prince like he's at
that at that level but unfortunately
it's mixed with a lot of things where
people don't see the talent because it's
he just comes across as a personality or
something
foreign